a search and rescue official involved in
finding a missing hiker in utah
has told a local tv station that parts
of her story
do not add up holly courtier of los
angeles was rescued in zion national
park sunday
12 days after she was last seen the
national park service says it's still
investigating carter evans spoke with
cortier's sister who told us
more about the circumstances leading to
her disappearance
and rescue she would have died for sure
if we want to found her jamie cordier
strong says her sister holly was
severely malnourished and had reportedly
lost
15 pounds by the time rescuers
discovered her after nearly two weeks
missing
in zion national park she was crying to
me and saying
like that she would just pray to be
found
her sister says holly was planning a
solo trip to the park
but never told her family she thought
i'll just
go and be with nature for a couple days
it sounds like she wanted to be off the
grid she did
initially she wanted to be off the grid
she did not
want to be off the grid for 12 days to
make matters worse she started fasting a
couple of days before the trip
and intended to keep fasting and so she
became extremely
weak very early on the first day or two
because she
wasn't eating or drinking she says that
made her sister
extremely disoriented at one point
hitting her head on a tree
causing a concussion she just said that
she felt like she was dying a slow death
after days of agony keeping track of the
passing time on a nearby
tree jamie says her sister was finally
found by a woman and her son on a hike
we knew she had that hammock with her
and they spotted the hammock hanging in
the tree
and they called in a tip jamie and the
rest of the family are just happy
holly's safe now
but they say she's learned a valuable
lesson when we explain to her
how this is not a normal thing to do you
know to you you can go off the grid
properly and not have people be
concerned
i think she now understands that she
didn't mean to cause worry
for cbs this morning i'm carter evans
well we echo what carter said i think
we're glad that she's safe and that
she's sound
you know now when you hear officials
raising questions there seems to be more
of the story
it's very confusing and it's hard to
understand why someone starts fasting
before they
go off the grid you know there are still
some questions there